good afternoon everyone welcome to the
daily briefing I do not have anything at
the top so I'm going to go ahead and
open it up for questions can we start
with Syria and maybe never leave Syria
actually and the you what's going on or
what did go on at the UN earlier is it
the administration's position that UN
authorization is required for any kind
of response that you might undertake and
did you or do you have any feelings
about what the British moved to get
apparently unsuccessfully to try and get
Auto is a shin mm-hmm well as you know
the p5 just met this morning to discuss
the text of a draft UN Security Council
resolution which as you pointed out was
drafted by our UK counterparts we've
consistently said that we support UN
Security Council action my understanding
is that today we heard nothing different
from the Russians and today's meeting
then we have four months and indeed
years about Syria including it will just
go through some of the history here
three vetoes of UN Security Council
resolutions just last week the Russians
blocked a press statement a potential
press statement condemning the attack
without even assigning culpability so we
have no reason to believe that efforts
at the Security Council would be any
different than these previous efforts
that have failed okay but that's me
that's good to know but um do you
believe that a UN Security Council
authorization is required for any kind
of response to the chemical weapons
attack well I'd say a few points first
is if there's been no decision made on
what the response will be second in
gardens are you upset can I make my
second point please and then if you have
a follow-up we'll get to that next well
while our initial read of the text put
forward this morning is that it is a
strong and compelling txt we see no
Avenue forward given continued Russian
opposition to any meaningful council
action on Syria therefore the United
States will continue its consultations
and will take appropriate actions to
respond in the days ahead I think I
would like to point out a statement that
I think is appropriate from William
Hague the Foreign
I think he made it recently that the UN
Security Council should rise to its
responsibilities by condemning these
events and calling for a robust
international response but all previous
attempts to get the Security Council to
act on Syria have been blocked and we
cannot allow diplomatic paralysis to be
a shield for the perpetrators of these
crimes I think we would certainly share
that view right but my question is do
you believe that UN Security Council
authorization is required to make
whatever response you're going to come
up with legal well as I just said we see
no Avenue going forward given continue
to rub it Russian opposition to any
meaningful council action we will
continue our consultations and take
appropriate action going forward I don't
have anything further for you than that
yes I follow up on this specific
question though it seems as though the
US and its allies on the Security
Council deemed the Security Council an
appropriate venue for some sort of
preliminary diplomatic action that would
proceed whatever other actions going to
follow but having not gotten the result
desired from that venue is then blindly
moving on and saying we really don't
need that venue to do what we want to do
well I'd make a few points we've
consistently said that we support UN
Security Council action instead what
we've seen not just today not just last
week but over the course of many months
is the Russians at every move doing
things to fail to hold the Syrian regime
accountable they've had three
resolutions vetoed as I said they've
blocked many other statements condemning
the Syrian regime so we do not believe
that the Syrian regime should be able to
hide behind the fact that the Russians
continue to block action on Syria at the
UN and we will make our decisions on
appropriate action going forward and we
will stay in close consultation with the
United Nations with the Secretary
General with our partners on the p5 and
around the world so in other words if
you don't get the verdict or result that
you want from the Security Council then
you blow off the Security Council and do
with your allies what you plan to do
anyway right I think I would respond to
that by saying we believe it's very
important as others have said including
the Arab League the most important
regional
a group of Arab nations that the Syrian
regime needs to be held accountable here
we firmly believe that we will take
action towards that end after the
president makes a decision and that's
what we're going to do going forward so
why did you bother with the Security
Council the first place if you are so
accustomed to Russian obstructionism
there well we believe it's an important
venue obviously again the p5 just met
this morning we we value the work of the
UN we've long said that we welcome un
actions on Syria this case was no
different but again we cannot be held up
in responding by Russia's intransigence
continued intransigence at the United
Nations that quite frankly the situation
is so serious that it demands a response
yes I shall not take it to a vote in
effect and in effect dare the Russians
to veto again again in terms of a vote
we don't see an avenue going forward
with a vote given continued Russian
opposition and I would underscore again
as I did yesterday that no decisions
been made so much of this is
hypothetical but but again that's our
position and I don't think I have much
further than that are you afraid that if
you took it to a vote and the Russians
vetoed as they have the three previous
efforts that you would then have man if
the manuf made manifest the absence of
Security Council authorization in fact
you would have it be very clear that
Security Council had ultimately decided
not to authorize such a resolution are
you afraid that that makes anything you
might do much harder I'm not going to
venture a guess and answering that
question I think the Russians have made
clear repeatedly what their point of
view is I don't think there's any secret
about where the Russians stand on Syria
in the Security Council so it's not like
anybody's hiding anything here we just
at this point don't think it's the
proper course of action so do you
believe that the u.s. decision to bomb
kosovo in or to bomb excuse me serbia
and 99 was
legal I'm not going to do a legal
analysis on many things but certainly
not a historical event that happened
some time ago I just don't think that's
relevant for this discussion for all
historical events happened some time ago
and I don't see and it's actually i
would think be easier to talk about
history because it's 14 years ago i'm
not going to do legal now if you don't
have you don't think Kosovo's relevant
to the current discussion of my room i'm
not going to do legal analysis from this
podium on past conflicts that we've been
involved in I'm just not going to do it
do you think it is important for the
United States in it the conduct of its
foreign policy to act legally I do when
I make a few points here I think that
it's clear that Syria violated our
national law here they used chemical
weapons in an indiscriminate manner with
respect to civilians that's you know
they violated the general laws of war we
talked a little bit yesterday and we can
talk a little bit more about the
international norms surrounding this
issue I also think it's clear that there
are core national security interests at
stake for the United States here the
mass scale use of chemical weapons or of
course the potential proliferation of
those weapons flagrantly violates an
important international norm and
threatens American national security and
as I said yesterday this is taking place
in a region that's already incredibly
destabilized taking place in the country
the borders and many countries are
allies and friends that we work closely
with together so we believe that it's
important that we send a strong message
that this type of mass scale
indiscriminate use of chemical weapons
is not acceptable where we can you
comment on something that that your
colleague Jay Carney articulated at
yesterday's White House briefing he
stated that I'm paraphrasing but
faithfully that I appreciate the face of
the fidelity he stated essentially that
in making his decision presently
President Obama sees the actions he will
take here as separate from the ongoing
Syrian civil war conflict in which the
United States has certain other
interests and simply that the actions
the president will take will be narrowly
tailored to this violation of
international norms I wonder if you
could explain why that is the the the
frame in which policy makers are acting
right now when it would seem to make a
certain amount of sense that any action
should assure Lee affect the Syrian
civil war conflict and not just relate
to this particular event which killed
about a thousand people in a conflict
that's killed a hundred thousand well I
make a few points and I think we can
actually do both at the same time the
decision the president is currently in
making and discussing it with his
national security team is how best to
respond to this this one massive use of
chemical weapons there will be a
response to that the president will make
that decision when he thinks it's
appropriate to do so going forward but
broadly speaking we have consistently
said that we don't believe there's a
military solution to this conflict in
Syria that we believe the only durable
solution that's best for the Syrian
people is a political solution so while
at the same time we make decisions about
how to respond to this chemical weapons
attack we will continue strengthening
the opposition working with the
opposition as we've continued to do in
the past months but also working towards
a political solution that we believe is
the only durable way to actually end
this conflict so you don't think that
the smart application of military power
can bring about this the set of
conditions that would facilitate a
diplomatic solution why I think that's a
different question actually I think the
options that the president's looking at
here and again I'm going to keep
stressing he hasn't made a decision yet
is how to respond in this specific
instance obviously we continue to
determine the best path forward how we
can best support the opposition as we've
done for months in changing the
situation on the ground helping them
grow in strength and eventually getting
both sides to the table and a Geneva
like process we give you all of them at
the same time actually real quickly that
I want to run through with you is there
a concern that the kind of strikes that
are under consideration could embolden
our adversaries in that region in what
way well again not
to get all historical on you but when in
1998 president clinton launched limited
strikes in response to the embassy
bombings we saw that followed up by the
coal incident and 911 is there a concern
that a very limited kind of surgical
strike such as appears to be under
consideration here could in fact wind up
in bolding our adversaries well I think
that as we determine and decide and
debate what steps will be taken in
response to this attack clearly there
are a variety of factors that go into
that determination possible unintended
consequences possible effects in the
region all of that is part of this big
picture that we look at the team looks
at when they decide what to do next but
let's be clear here we firmly believe
that this was such a gross violation of
an international norm against the use of
chemical weapons that we need to respond
and we actually I think it's important
and I would make a few points here about
the Arab League statement that we very
much welcome to that statement the most
important regional group a group of Arab
countries forcefully saying that they
condemn the use of chemical weapons and
that they called on the international
community to hold the Syrian regime
fully accountable for this crime so
clearly there are a number of people in
the region other Arab countries calling
on the world to hold the regime
accountable we think that that's very
important to less things you've been
very patient and I appreciate my
colleagues patience you've talked at
great length about the diplomacy that is
underway well with respect to our allies
is there any diplomacy underway with
respect to President Assad any US
diplomacy not to my knowledge migratory
didn't call him wall in last week last
week yeah he asked about presents not
specifically well well I meant the Assad
regime in other words has is it a
different question is it the view of the
United States government that any
possibilities for diplomacy with the
Assad regime with respect to this
specific incident of August 21 have been
exhausted I don't want to go that far
today just because quite frankly I don't
I don't know the answer to that I know
that the secretary called the Foreign
Minister last week to make a very direct
demand that the UN investigators be
allowed in immediately with unfettered
access I don't want to make a broader
statement than that
if I have any updates on our policy on
that I'm happy to get back to you last
question you've asserted repeatedly from
the from the podium that it is the
belief of the United States government
based on intelligence that the Assad
regime maintains full control over its
chemical weapons arsenal I wonder if you
could flush that out for us a bit
because as you know in the deployment of
a chemical weapons or chemical weapon or
munitions armed with chemical weapons
there are several layers through which
in order has to proceed and I wonder if
you are telling us that you believe that
President Assad himself maintains full
control command and control over the
chemical weapons arsenal or whether you
think that that that control is
exercised some mid-level or tell us what
you mean when you say you think the
regime maintains full control it's a
good question and I don't have a lot of
information about that for you if I can
share more about that I will I think I
make a few points that we ultimately of
course hold President Assad responsible
for the use of chemical weapons by his
regime against his own people regardless
of where the command and control lies I
don't have more details for you on that
specifically obviously we've said that
the regime maintains control of these
weapons and that the opposition of
course doesn't have the capability to
use them and if I have more to share
with you about the specific command and
control i will i just don't do you will
leave that here in this attack i I don't
I don't know the answer to that but if
he or his people didn't have anything I
don't understand how you can say does it
doesn't matter where the commanding it
doesn't matter he is ultimately held
responsible for the actions of his
regime regardless of regardless of what
he pressured doesn't matter how can you
all do accountable regardless where the
command control jaffe the command and
control doesn't rest within him or his
you know people below him in the food
chain how do you hold him responsible
well let's be clear the
commander-in-chief of any military is
ultimately responsible for decisions
made under their leadership even if
command and control you know he's not
the one that pushes the button or says
go on this and again I don't know what
this
rocks are here I'm just broadly speaking
saying that he is responsible for the
actions of his regime I'm not intimately
familiar with the command and control
structure of the Syrian military I'm
just not but again he is responsible
ultimately for the trees that are made
so it doesn't matter to you whether he
personally gave an order it doesn't get
responsible at this it doesn't matter
there was either way depending on me not
and again I just actually don't know the
fact later on instant something extra it
does not matter whether President Assad
himself gave in order to use chemical
weapons he's responsible for their years
it doesn't matter is that correct he's
responsible either way yeah so if some
rogue officer did this it's still his
responsibility that's that's well a yes
but that's also a wildly conjecture is
question that I think in no way there's
evidence supporting right now stick with
it but thank you yeah but let's be clear
here that based on multiple independent
streams of information widely available
that again I will say the only logical
conclusion is that the Assad regime
itself was responsible for the use of
chemical weapons in this attack you're
familiar with reports that the rebels
have had access to and have used sarin
in this conflict correct we do not
assess it the rebels the rebels the
opposition excuse me that the opposition
have the capabilities to use these kinds
of weapons we don't that's art that
remains our assessment but is it your
assessment that they have at any time
possessed sarin III don't have anything
for you on that i actually just don't
know the answer but our assessment
remains crystal clear that they don't
have the capability the opposition that
you support not the al-qaeda we also
insisted on this or does not have the
ability to use these kinds of weapons
again to let's talk for a second let's
step back and talk about what this was
this was a massive large-scale multiple
multiple faceted attack against a wide
swath of area using very sophisticated
rockets very sophisticated delivery
systems that were armed with chemical
weapons there's one party in Syria who
has the capability to do that and it's
the Assad regime
what does that mean it wasn't just one
alleged rocket there were multiple
Rockets over a wide swath of areas in
the suburbs of Damascus you said
multiple delivery systems I think of
rockets as one delivery system get my
good multiple delivery systems I
misspoke i met multiple rockets fired
through a certain deliveries okay and
then second um as you may have seen a
little while before you came out the
actually not a little while about an
hour and a half before the Syrian
ambassador to the United Nations said
that he was asking for he sort of
renewed the claim that the opposition
may have been behind this and he wanted
he called for the UN investment to look
into this more given that you have long
argued where your predecessors from this
podium that the UN inspectors should be
given full access do you think that they
their mandate should be extended so as
to allow them to look into these
allegations well I think that's a
hypothetical actually that has no
bearing on the situation it's a strange
statement I think from the Syrian
ambassador to the UN because the Mandate
of the UN investigation isn't to
determine culpability so he was calling
on them to do something that under
mandate they can't actually do well do
you think that they should be given more
time to look into do you agree with his
call for them to have more time to look
into use of chemical weapons regardless
of response to any response I think his
call would have credibility if on day
one or two or three or four or five the
Syrian regime had stopped shelling the
area that they attacked to
systematically destroy evidence to cover
up what they had done and actually loud
allowed UN investigators in its it's an
interesting fact that today a week after
this attack he says they should be
allowed in when every single step the
Syrian regime has taken up until this
point has been to actually stall and
stymie this investigation so the the
word speak speak much quieter than
actions I think actions here what
matters and every
from the Syrian regime has been that
they will not cooperate with us I think
they're trying to install a response to
what you described as the massive use of
chemical weapons III don't want to
venture to guess why they're doing what
they're doing but I think it's clear
that we will not allow them to hide
behind a UN investigation into the use
of chemical weapons to prevent any
response from the United States if you
had a have you had have you received
from the UN its assessment I don't know
the answer to that I can look into it
because if you haven't why would you
argue that they are hiding behind that I
mean you yourselves repeatedly called
for the UN investigation it is well the
Syrian regime is trying to hide behind
it because they keep referencing it
publicly with their words but their
actions speak a very different story
that they keep saying oh we just need
more time we just need more time when
all they've done in the time that's
elapsed since the attack is
systematically destroy evidence they've
made the security situation on the
ground much more difficult for the UN
investigative team so there are claims
that they just need more time just have
absolutely no credibility when
everything they've done up to this point
spoke actually the opposite reality when
you said their claims that they just
need more time that they with you I was
referring the Syrian regime not to their
say not the Syrian government saying
that the inspectors just need more time
no I was referring to I think what you
were referring to the Syrian regime's
comments that they should be given more
time for the inspection to go forward on
the ground when everything they've done
actually is an opposition to that today
with the inspector should be given item
yes correct I'm sorry if I wasn't ether
there yes and then I'll go to the US
sharing plans at the SP they publicly
said that there in the dark sharing
plans about what I guess next step
forward well I would reiterate yet again
that no decision has been made about
what our next steps will be here our
response but I can say that yesterday
our coordinator for us assistance the
Syrian crisis mark ward spoke with
general Idris who reaffirmed that his
forces would protect
un investigators if they're allowed to
return to opposition controlled
territory they've been saying this to us
all along so this again is another data
point that the opposition has pledged
that they will help the inspectors and
the regime is the one preventing them to
we would also add that a range of us
officials remain in regular contact with
the leadership and staff of both the SOC
and the SMC a best afford is an Istanbul
still meeting with opposition leaders
including SSC president jarba and with
counterparts from our allies and
partners as well yes will you wait the
result of the inspection I mean the
media wait the result of the work of the
UN inspection inspectors who are working
on the field repeat the first part of
your question may be a result of the
report of doing UN inspectors well I
think I said yesterday and I'll repeat
again that we believe that it's too late
for the UN inspection to be credible
given the mass shelling that the regime
has done in the affected areas and we're
going to make our own decisions on our
own timelines about our response
obviously we will continue consultations
with our international partners around
the world but we are making decisions
based on our own timeline UN Secretary
General said that the inspectors need
four more days it's a reasonable
timeline for you again we are making our
own decisions on our own timeline and we
believe that the UN inspection has
passed the point where it can be
credible and and again I'm going to
repeat let's be clear they cannot
determine by mandate culpability they
can only determine whether a chemical
weapons attack happened and there is
absolutely a hundred percent no doubt in
anyone's mind here that a chemical
weapons attack happened so because the
security situation isn't safe also
because we believe the regime is trying
to use the UN investigation as to hide
behind in to stall that it's past the
point of credibility and we will make
our own decisions on our own timeline
going forward the last question about
they are a big statement the
administration is satisfied with the
statement as I understood the Arab
League statement yeah very very much
welcomed it yet do you believe that the
statement is supporting in relative
interventional either by date with well
let me be clear we did not ask the Arab
League for authorization for an action
that hasn't been decided that we were
going to take yet there I know there
were some reports out there too and all
those reports are actually false this
was not in any way the purpose of this
statement we very much welcome the
statement for strongly condemning the
regime's use of chemical weapons and
calling for international response to
hold them accountable well in fact the
statement doesn't say it does call for
an international response but what it
says is that it would like the UN
Security Council members to overcome
their differences and agree to something
to hold the Assad regime I remember
being clear that we would welcome that
response by the UN Security sket Council
but your Russians have been clear that
they have no interest in holding the
Syrian regime accountable and therefore
we will move forward on our own but the
Arab League statement doesn't say and in
the absence of a Security Council
resolution we think it would be good
idea for the United States or for any
other country to go ahead and do
whatever it wants to doesn't say that
again the Arab League statement was a
very strong statement that the regime
needs to be held accountable the Arab
League is also fully aware of the
dynamics on the Security Council and
Russia's position on Syria so I think
that again there's not that much more to
it we welcome to statement the reports
out there saying we had asked for
something we didn't get from the
statement are just actually address okay
I don't know what report you're talking
about but so you disagree with the UN
envoy Brahimi who says that Security
Council authorization is needed for
action that correct again we don't see
an avenue forward here in the security
council voting on this draft resolution
and we are going to take appropriate
actions to respond in the days ahead
even with that even in the absence of
the Security Council again I'm not going
to get into hypotheticals about a
decision that hasn't been made but I
think I just made clear that we are not
proceeding with rose on this draft
resolution the other thing you said the
other thing you said earlier and then
you changed it you said there was no
question that the Syrians had violated
violated international
long that still that stands because then
you then you reverted back to
international norm and different ya know
I I did not know the internet ok so the
international law that they violated is
based on the fact that they used
chemical weapons in the indiscriminate
manner with respect to civilians which
is a general law of war that countries
have agreed to and it is a clear
violation of international law Syria to
the best of your knowledge ever agree to
that I believe that it is a general law
of war that governs all conflicts and
and so therefore they're in violation of
it you know how they violated it again
that it's a gross violation of that
international on i'm not going to do
more legal analysis than that what law
can you point to a specific i'm not
going to do a more detailed legal
analysis nobody's asking you for more
detail but i think you are nothing for
detailed legal analysis this is a very
simple no no let me finish is a very
simple and undetailed question what
piece of paper are you talking about
when you talk about that piece of
international law well there is a
general set of rules that govern
conflicts we've talked about this here
and I can get you more details if I can
but the indiscriminate use of chemical
weapons against civilians is a violation
of international law I also talked a
little bit about international norms and
the Chemical Weapons Convention which
they are obviously not a party to but
which clearly laid out that a majority
of vast majority of the world spoke up
and said that we are taking a stand
against chemical weapons and and the
world has spoken on chemical weapons and
we're not going back and they have to be
held accountable you see the president
you're setting let me guess let me just
go here he's been waiting very patiently
then I'll go to you giving us in a
position to the UN Security Council
resolution music do you think at this
point of time administration things at
going to UN Security Council and CJ's a
futile exercise again I think I've made
our point our position on whether we're
going to proceed at this point with a
Security Council vote resolution of
resolution vote excuse me and we're not
going to assist and secondly
single area among the e5 what about
China are you satisfied the Chinese
position Syria are they on board with
you or they're not the alterations again
I don't have all the details from this
morning's p5 meeting I got a brief
readout of it from my colleagues who
were there I think it's been clear that
Russia has really been the most
intransigent excuse me a member of the
p5 on Syria so that that was what I was
told was the sticking point this morning
in the meeting and I don't have more
details for you than that yes thank you
it is reported that the North Korea no
we're not gonna know it's not an area
it's a link is in the video North Korea
thought you're getting ahead of us yeah
North Korea provided the chemical
weapons to Syria do you have any
information on this whether North Korea
expert chemical weapons to Syria I don't
have anything for you on that I'm happy
to look into it and get back to if I do
I just don't have anything for you let
me go to James and then pop up to you
you know it just seems as though what
you're saying in essence is we believe
the United Nations Security Council is a
very important venue we wanted something
out of that venue but we were blocked by
one of the other members in good
standing which has veto power therefore
we can't be held back by that and we're
just going to go ahead anyway and I just
wonder if you're if you're cognizant of
the precedent that that sets for Russia
or China or any other member of the
Security Council which may feel well
we're going to be blocked by the United
States on something so let's just move
forward outside of the Security Council
you understand the point I'm making I do
I would make a few points in response
the first is that we sat down today with
the Russians and the rest of the p5
member states and talk through the
issues and laid out the fact that this
was such a gross violation we felt the
Security Council should respond we also
at the same time believe while weeds
welcome Security Council resolutions in
action on Syria that you cannot allow a
regime to go unpunished for a gross
violation here where they used chemical
weapons on a massive scale against their
own people so I understand your question
we firmly believe that we worked through
the
security council process this morning
clearly Russia it remains intransigent
on it and we feel it is imperative for
us in the international community to
respond because no no no I wouldn't say
that I wouldn't fit that but that's a
gross generalization based on one
situation where we believe that the
violation is so great that there was
such it was such a over the pale gross
use of chemical weapons that we need to
respond and that Syria cannot hide
behind Russian intransigence at the
Security Council we're not accessible
punching this question I'm given the
rhetoric that you're using about Russia
and that we've seen out of Russia about
the United States and the fact that you
say you still want to pursue a political
solution is there some concern that the
tension right now the friction between
the US Russia is going to make it hard
to cooperate on getting toward Geneva 2
if and when we ever get there well I
think to be clear it hasn't been a
secret that we've had strong
disagreements with Russia for months
over Syria including in the other three
times they vetoed Syria resolution so
it's not like this disagreement with
Russia just started in the last week so
and during that if i cain't miles and
during that time we've worked with him
on Geneva I I think a couple points we
said yesterday that we remain committed
to working with the Russians on the
Geneva process we know it's going to be
difficult of course but we remain
committed in the Russians we have no
indications that the Russians don't
remain committed as well to a Geneva
like process which they've repeatedly
reaffirmed and to an eventual political
solution which we believe is the only
solution here so we're going to keep
working through it with them it's
certainly not easy but it's in the best
interest of the Syrian people that quite
frankly we do what was the u.s. use of
nuclear weapons resulting in the mass
and indiscriminate killing of civilians
in both Hiroshima and Nagasaki a
violation of the same international law
that you're referring to
I'm not even going to entertain that
question I tried can I tonight can I ask
you maybe you got an answer to my
question from yesterday which wasn't
honestly a trick question thought it
would you convince me of that later I
believe you all right good go on with
your terms of butter but in terms of the
precedent yeah is there that you're
aware of precedent for for a US
administration or any other government
that you're aware of to use the use of
chemical weapons as a justification to
take some kind of retaliatory or
punitive action no not to that specific
question there is there so there is no
precedent for this not that I am aware
of so okay so this is like this is on
right and it's what the answer that I
thought I thought when it's a non-trans
I hear the answer is correct however
that previous American administrations
have taken action against countries
based on the threat of possible use but
never the actual use my understand
though in terms of years no no no no
more there was something else coming no
I just need to so this would be an
unprecedented did this response whatever
it's going to be is unprecedented I
think you said that the point there
before you get to your next question I
would remind you that the Chemical
Weapons Convention went into force in
1997 and since then we haven't actually
seen a massive use of chemical weapons
in the same way that we just saw
recently so they're actually hasn't been
seen since the convention wanted to use
I would just make that historical point
right but since Syria is neither a
signatory nor again they can't hide
behind it ninety-eight percent of the
world's people live in countries that
have acceded to it well you know the
United States is not a member of the
Convention on child soldiers and yet
you're
a member of numerous things including
the International Criminal Court so
that's the dangerous position to have if
you're going to say that you're you
don't consider yourself the united
states states does not consider itself
bound by the International Criminal
Court so why should Syria consider
itself to be bound by the chemical
weapons convention that's quite a
separate question entirely what I want
to get into is that this is
unprecedented there is no international
law then that would justify or give you
a legal cover for a response to this
that you think that you're aware of i am
not going to do any sort of legal
analysis about potential responses that
haven't been decided on from this podium
i'm just not going to do it the military
information does the administration is
that the administration concerned about
the day likely intervention would help
al Qaeda with fighting which is fighting
with the regime in which I don't
understand your question play that out a
little bit analytically and then maybe I
can answer it better so to a military
intervention against the Assad regime
would help the al-qaeda forces in the
region this that's the idea that's the
criticism against the administration are
you concerned about that well first I
would again reiterate that no decision
has been made so we're getting a little
ahead of ourselves here but secondly
obviously we believe that the Assad
regime has to be held accountable and we
have to respond to this use of chemical
weapons separate and apart from that we
actually have said repeatedly that the
Syrian conflict perpetrated by the Assad
regime is what's responsible for the
recent uptick and al-qaeda activity in
the region what's responsible for
increased al-qaeda attacks in places
like Iraq and also terrorist attacks in
Lebanon so I think we put the blame
squarely on the Assad regime for
fomenting chaos in their own country
which has then spread throughout the
rest of the region often in the form of
horrific terrorist attacks that quite
frankly we hadn't even seen a few months
ago in Iraq
authorization issue as we know Barrack
Obama said in an interview last week
that the United States would consider
international law if America goes in or
attacked another country so we know
Barack Obama hasn't made any decision
yet but the Pentagon said is ready all
the information here and what he said on
this podium and since all the
information signals that he is not going
to seek authorization from UN or US
Congress this time if I think you're
getting a little ahead of the ball game
here I i think a I will let the
president's words speak for themselves
we've said for a year that the president
has a range of military contingencies on
his table regarding Syria for when and
if you would ever need to use them again
we're not talking about boots on the
ground we're not talking about no-fly
zones at this point so I would refrain
from doing any further legal analysis
and I also don't want folks to make
assumptions about what we might or might
not do about a decision that hasn't been
made we will keep consulting very
closely with Congress as we have
throughout the process and will continue
to do so but it's out of session go to
you next they also have cell phones that
miraculously work all across the country
and secretary Kerry and others have been
in close contact with our congressional
leaders as well no reason in Northwest
look let me kick go here and then if you
have a question that's not self
unrelated change of subject I think
maybe we're still on Syria and then I'll
come to you next come on look you keep
saying that that you don't want to
engage in any legal analysis from the
podium has the office of the legal
advisor or any lawyers who work here at
the State Department have any of them
been tasked with developing any kind of
legal rationale for what the president
is considering i'm not going to go into
any internal discussions or
deliberations about possible courses of
action including that one however
whatever response the administration
comes up with will be will comply with
international law again Matt I'm going
to keep saying this I'm not going to
answer in any way any questions about
any legal analysis period full stop
studio from this podium what does that
mean that you're not you're saying that
the u.s. might act outside of enter
not what I'm saying I'm just not even
going to answer any questions on legal
rationales at all period i'm not going
to do any analysis from here on that
next question yes you said yesterday
that classified version of the
intelligence report would be given to
Congress this week in a unclassified
version made available publicly if you
have an update on when that one I don't
have an update I understand that the
classified intelligence assessment has
not yet been sent to the Congress
obviously we continue our regular
consultations with Congress but let me
take a few moments to make some comments
about the intelligence community
assessment as I said once we have the
intelligence community excuse me has
made a formal assessment we will provide
the classified assessment to Congress
and then make unclassified details
available to the public expect that as
we said to occur sometime this week it's
important to remember I know there's
been a lot of press reporting and
conjecture about what may or may not be
in this intelligence assessment that the
protection of sources and methods must
be taken into account when the
intelligence community determines what
information can be declassified and
released to the public while the
Congress obviously will receive a
classified version that includes the
broad range of intelligence collected
the intelligence intelligence
information we are able to provide
publicly will be limited in scope for a
variety of reasons obviously we need to
protect sources and message for example
to be able to use them in the future to
detect future use of these kinds of
weapons so I just want to set
expectations a little bit there's been a
lot of discussion and debate about this
I think I would also say that while I
can't speak to what intelligence related
to the august twenty-first attack will
eventually be declassified I would
caution against anyone assuming that any
signals intelligence or any human
intelligence will be included in that
unclassified version is it safe to say
that the that the course the president
is deciding upon will entail deterrence
from future such actions not merely by
inflicting random and wantin pain on the
regime but by in fact degrading the
regime's ability physical ability to
do this again I think again while a
decision hasn't been made broadly
speaking those are two goals I think
that we have clearly it's important for
the international community to say
strongly that this is not an acceptable
course of action and to deter future use
of chemical weapons as well so I think
broadly speaking that's not an unfair
assessment but again no decision has
been made so I don't want to go much
further in terms of goals of a final
course of action are you seeing your
comments about what may or may not be in
this intelligence assessment basically
you're saying it could be it may end up
being just regurgitating of the standard
talking points that we've been hearing
from you and the White House over the
last couple days I'm not saying that at
all i'm trying to set expectations
because there's been a lot of press
reports about guessing or get a hearing
reports about what may or may not be
included in the classified version some
of those reports refer two types of
intelligence that would never or would
almost never be included in an
unclassified version so I'm just trying
to set expectations i'm not trying to in
any way say that the intelligence
assessment will look like what I say to
you every day okay well i mean well i
mean you're trying to set expectations
low right i'm trying to set expectations
realistically realistically so
realistically we should not expect any
kind of smoking gun evidence that that
that the Assad regime was oh I wouldn't
need that Matt I wouldn't say that I'm
saying certain kinds of intelligence for
very good reasons aren't going to be
included but also let's step back for a
second and review what we already know
publicly there's a lot of what I would
actually call smoking gun evidence that
is publicly available that a mass
chemical weapons attack happened as if
the Assad regime did it so separate and
apart from the intelligence assessment
the world doesn't need a classified US
intelligence assessment to see the
photos and the videos of these people
and to know that the only possible
entity in Syria that could do this to
their own people is the regime what they
don't need an assessment from me I see
to tell them that right but they may
need something more than Marie harf
getting up and saying we're going to
bomb Syria because I say they did this
well I am NOT saying that and me we are
going to be providing an unclass
five version of the intelligence
assessment again I'm just trying to set
expectations here realistically okay I
just want to make sure that I understood
idea for the Brits to come out to try to
push a resolution at the UN well clearly
we tactically the UK made a decision and
work in full agreement with them about
the need to hold the regime accountable
we didn't I don't believe see the draft
before it came up this morning but we
work very closely with them and we have
supported UN Security Council efforts to
hold Syria accountable right I
understand but but because of the way
you knew going into this meeting that
was held this morning that the Russians
were going to be a stress and
obstruction we gave them an opportunity
not to be right but you knew that they
would be I mean you know what they
didn't take no one was betting that they
were actually going to change their
position that they've had to land we are
all realistic about whether Russia does
you knew that there was no chance of
this going ahead given the fact that you
knew that there was no chance that they
were going to let this go through do you
think it was a good idea for the Brits
to push this so hard for whatever reason
that they did again we think it's
important to engage the Security Council
particularly the p5 on this issue right
but then you say it's important to
engage and as soon as they they don't
engage the way you want them to you walk
away and say it's not important to
engage you say nothing it's not
important i'm saying that is what is it
we see no Avenue forward in the security
counts I'm not saying it's not important
Matt I'm saying that what is crucial
right now is holding the Syrian regime
accountable we will make our own
decisions on our own time in conjunction
with our partners the president will
make a decision at some point which we
will announce to all of you at that time
but that's what we're focused on right
now is holding the regime accountable
right not focused on building a legal
case or and the only reason that this is
coming up is because people in the UN
system and outside the UN system aren't
say that in order to act with within
international law there's got to be some
kind of some kind of authorization even
the Bush administration had a resolution
on Iraq now there were differences
interpretation / what consequences meant
but they had a piece of paper well first
I would in no way compared
at all period to Iraq so let's set that
aside and if you want to talk more about
that I can but what I will say is we are
making decisions that are in our
national security interest we are
consulting with our allies and partners
including the UN but we do not believe
that the Syrian regime should be able to
hide behind the UN a UN Security Council
process here that the Russians have
prevented from holding the regime
accountable period I don't want to get
into a comparison of the circumstances
with Iraq but i do want to point make
the point or a have you addressed the
point that the bush administration was
not known for being a particularly big
fan of united nations and yet they
sought and won a resolution that they
thought nope not many other people
thought that gave them the authority the
legal justification to invade iraq well
this latest preciate was exactly that
their interpretation was that that
resolution which called for severe
consequences meant what was the gave
them the legal authorization this
administration which has made it a point
to say that it wants to work with the UN
and work within the international system
headed by a president who won a nobel
peace prize is now saying that it not
even worth the effort to get to try to
get that kind of a an authorization
nothing is not worth the effort Matt if
it was your sorry just say that there's
no there's no reason there's no Avenue
that you don't see a point there's no
Avenue you just said that the Russians
are never going to sign on to anything
so it's not that it's not worth the
effort that we know what the outcome
will be an official demonstrated this
morning that they are not interested in
holding the Syrian regime accountable
here what I will say so in the in the
playground pleasure at the playground of
international diplomacy here you don't
get what you want you're going to take
your ball and go home well actually I
strongly disagree with that you look at
the dozens and dozens of calls and
discussions that the secretary Kerry the
president secretary Hagel have had with
our counterparts across the world
whether its NATO the air oblique a host
of countries in the Middle East in
Europe elsewhere clearly we are
consulting the international community
and a broad range of international
partners on the best course forward the
UN is is the only international body
that we're consulting here but again we
continue talking to the
secretary-general as well so it's not
like we are not engaging in high-level
sustained consultations with our
diplomatic partners in fact it's
actually the opposite okay so you think
that another there is another avenue to
get to get Ali over again I'm not going
to do any sort of legal analysis at all
period from this podium follow up on
that can you run through the Secretary's
recent calls or meetings of significance
on this yes so there are no new calls
today on Syria that I have to read out I
know we sent around a list last evening
there was one more from last evening
that occurred after we sent the list out
because the secretary is clearly working
late on this it was to Saudi ambassador
to the US adil Andrew bear that's the
only addition from last night again
we'll send another update tonight if we
have any calls on Syria torito yes
mm-hmm oh wait Syria and North Korea are
just north korea no score yet okay are
there any more questions on Syria okay
we can go to North Korea visually the
six paths across delegation of a China
without a visit to North Korea today and
alchemy the North could it is partly top
validation King defiance what is the
United States view / resumption of the
six-party talks killings well clearly as
we all know the DPRK has committed on
numerous occasions including in
September 2005 joint statement on the
six-party talks to abandon their nuclear
weapons in existing nuclear programs and
we will continue to hold the DPRK to
those commitments and its international
obligations so clearly we think this is
the forum in which it should be
discussed the onus is on North Korea
here obviously we remain committed to
authentic incredible talks on
denuclearization beyond that I don't
have a specific response to these latest
round of talks but I'm happy to look
into that if I have anything more to
share i'll get back to do you think
within the base year party possibly be
agent I don't have any update for you on
that and
be to look into it and get back to if I
have more to share I just don't have
anything else inside geopolitics yes you
can ambassador Robert King is going
going to travel north korea this week
yeah to negotiate yeah on Friday to
negotiate the release of Kalispell first
are you optimistic that he will bring
mr. bad out of the country well what's
important here it is exactly that that
we want mr. BAE release we've made this
patently clear and as you just said at
the invitation of the North Korean
government ambassador King will travel
to Pyongyang on Friday on a humanitarian
mission solely focused on securing the
release of Kenneth BAE I don't want to
get ahead of where we are here it's more
hair so a couple days away so was there
was there an unconditional invitation or
a conditioner I'm not going to further
described that invitation again the
North Korean government invited
ambassador King to visit Pyongyang for
this purpose and again I'm sure we'll
talk about it more in the coming days
and that's just one more money you can
what I'm asking you is if North Korea
release mr. bad do you think it will be
conducive to the resumption of talks
between Kenya and Washington I don't
want to make that link at this point
clearly I'll we believe that we need to
work towards a denuclearized North Korea
that's an important process but I don't
want to link the two in any way we have
repeatedly said that separate and apart
from any of the other issues we talked
about with North Korea that Kenneth BAE
I need to be released immediately this
has been a human rights issue that we've
talked about so I'm just not going to
link with you okay last one I promise
okay do you think there's the chance
that ambassador King will discuss the
issue of humanitarian aid for North
Korea is true it's my understanding that
his mission is solely focused on
securing mr. BAE's release I don't have
more details for you than that again as
we get closer to and through the trip we
can talk about it more right yes for
money to be for the United States
release the kinect bay I don't have any
additional details for you on any we
discuss
surrounding this situation I don't have
anything more for you if we can share
more throughout the rest of the week
maybe ten thousand dollars I I don't
have anything else anything else where
you don't stay like to mommy the first
the first question was actually are you
are you optimistic can you say that you
are that you have hope you you're
hopeful that ambassador King will be
able to return with mr. BAE certainly
that's the goal of the trip and we've
repeatedly said that that's what needs
to happen through the new york channel
or with us through the Swedish
protecting power you know to coordinate
an ambassador Kings trip there I'm not
going to get into any more specifics
about the diplomacy that surrounded this
trip again I said this North Korean
government invited ambassador came to
Pyongyang and beyond that nothing
nothing for their for you at this time
yes Afghanistan yet President of
Afghanistan amiga joy have just
concluded his trip to slough bud mm-hmm
bascially how do you see trip well we
welcome any opportunity for increased
bilateral dialogue between Afghanistan
and Pakistan I think for any additional
details of the visit I'd refer you to
those two governments but again we would
welcome any opportunity like this one
for increased dialogue differences room
the two countries on counterterrorism
issues does remain the product classes
how to see is it affecting yo operations
inside Afghanistan well we've said that
Pakistan's own security and stability is
tied of course to a successful outcome
in Afghanistan and we've been
appreciative of Pakistan's efforts to
further reconciliation clearly there's
an ongoing process here but I don't have
any more details for you than that on
this specific visit and related of dust
and so having any development on
resumption of BSA thoughts I don't have
any update for you on that it's my
understanding that formal negotiations
have not resumed however as I've said
informal discussions are continuing in
Afghanistan led by our embassy there do
you have any reaction comment at all on
me DG
aggghhhhh latest one on Iran let me see
what I have on that the IAEA Director
General's report on around that you just
mentioned was released to the Board of
Governors on Wednesday August
twenty-eighth I'm not able to comment
publicly directly on the substance of
the report yet as it has not been
released publicly I understand that it
hasn't well I mean well the IE anyone
with a computer and an internet
connection can get it it has not been
released officially publicly yet but
that said Iran obviously remains a non
compliance with its international
nuclear obligations and in that context
we remain concerned about Iran's
continued expansion of its enrichment
capability so when you say continued
expansion of its enrichment capability
you're referring to the additional 1000
advanced centrifuges I'm not going to
further parse that again when this is
released publicly we can talk about it
more than anything else thank you thank
you